just sitting down and listening to
somebody
there's joy in that
i can put a smile on but inside feel
completely broken now that is from the
me you can't see that's a new series on
apple tv plus at premieres today
the multi-part documentary was
co-created by oprah and prince harry
the series is about mental health told
by real people
some famous some not they all struggle
with their emotional well-being oprah
and harry not only created it they both
appear in it to tell
their individual stories but they began
talking about this project
more than a year and a half ago to make
that
decision to receive help is not a sign
of weakness
in today's world more than ever it is a
sign of strength
from the first moment i had a
conversation with
prince harry about what were his two
most important issues facing the world
and he said climate change
and uh mental health and i started to
tell him about the series i was doing
with apple tv
plus he said oh and if you ever need any
help with that series let me know and i
went
what did you think when he when he
volunteered what did i think when he
volunteered
well my first initial thought was oh
yeah this is like let's have lunch
sometimes yes but it's fascinating to me
that you two are very different
yes yeah we even say that in the series
at one point i'm talking about growing
up with
you know no running water in an outhouse
and he was like well
i am the exact opposite of that so which
goes to show
that it doesn't matter whether you were
born in a castle or whether you're
you know born in an outhouse or born to
people who didn't really want you
we all have this spectrum of
our mental well-being in common he is
candid in this series
do you think that him being as candid as
he is
is going to help him with the royal
family
i don't know if it helps with the royal
family but this is what i do know
is that being able to express your own
personal truth in a way
that benefits you and also helps other
people to see the truth in themselves
which is the reason why
harry agreed to have the sit down and
have the conversation
uh the first the the interview that went
around the world
and in this series you will see that we
are in conversation
yes because he knows the power of story
he knows that by sharing the story of
his own
grief with his mother that
many other people who haven't processed
their grief will
say oh you know what that that's what's
going on with me too
and i quickly established that if this
relationship was
was going to work that i was going to
have to
deal with my past because there was
anger there
what was fascinating to me is that both
you and harry talk about your own
traumas
but for the first time i saw a different
kind of emotion and i'm wondering where
that came from
for you one of the things that hap that
has happened to me in this process
of talking about other people's stories
i've thought a lot about my
own and i realized that every single
thing that has happened
even when it was at its hardest was
happening to bring you to the you that
you
are right now if you just have one
person
that says i see you i truly see you i
get you
for me it was my teachers mrs duncan
oftentimes i learned this on my own show
why do people break down and cry because
nobody's ever asked them a question in
that way before
and every baby picture every little girl
picture i see of you you look so sad
and you've never had therapy well a girl
don't make me start crying you were my
therapist every night after
every show you and i would chat
we thought it was just talking but the
scientific term is
dosing so every night dosing dosing
dosing
and so you know the beauty of this is
that everybody doesn't have a gale in
their life
but there is a somebody that is willing
to see you
and hear your story and to validate you
what i like is you have a wide variety
of people and you have a wide variety of
ages and ethnicities
you know one of the most powerful
stories is that syrian refugee child
falzie and when his counselor says to
him
there are two sides warring there's the
dark side and the light
and we've got to bring you to the light
otherwise 20 years from now the little
boy that you are
will will still be warring you know with
the dark side
that moved me so much because i thought
about how many
young black boys are in the streets now
warring with
something that happened to them that
nobody was ever able to sit down and say
here's why you feel that way how do you
think the world changes when we know
each other's stories
we all become more human and we all
realize
that there is a common denominator in
our humanity
that there is a shared pain there is
shared struggle
as well as shared joys it allows us all
to see
the humanity in ourselves and in each
other
you know they believe there's a lot of
interest in this series because the
trailer millions of people it's the
highest rated trailer people just want
to see that
it dropped overnight there's five
episodes and
you know it's very well done in terms of
the people gaga is in it she goes by the
name stephanie her real name
glenn close is in it talking about her
sister robin william's son
is talking about his dad's uh when his
dad took his own life
and then names that you don't know but
it's something relatable for everybody a
very important subject
and i think it's going to change the way
people think and react to mental health
well we've
we've and they're both so candid we've
been having this conversation on this
show for a while now and the
conversation itself is so important but
when you can when you can elevate it to
that level i think i think it reaches a
lot of people